[Music]
hello gorgeous my name is mollock
now you might not have heard of me but
you've most certainly felt me
for i am the force behind fortune
the power behind progress and the shaper
of all success
and what a success even you
could be
if
you just listen to me
for i alone know what it takes to win
to be the most adored and the most
beautiful
and you do want all those things don't
you
yes
well listen close because there are
things you can do to tweak reality
weapons you can use to crush your
enemies
and you better use them because if you
don't
your enemies are going to use them to
crush you
i want to win
you see in the end the world wants
winners
not losers and life it isn't just a game
it's whoa
okay uh so today i want to talk about
beauty and specifically how new
technologies on social media are
changing our relationship with it
because even though we've been using all
kinds of tricks to make ourselves look
hotter for thousands of years it feels
like it's getting extra intense lately
like my instagram for example at the
moment is just serving me up endless
streams of insanely hot sort of
kardashian-faced beautiful women with
perfect makeup not to mention a ton of
plastic surgery recommendations thanks
algorithm
and if that's not enough psychological
torment for you now we have these ai
driven beauty face filter apps to
content with i mean just
look at this [ __ ] you can feed it with
the most horrific photo with no makeup
bad lighting you name it and with one
click bam it'll turn you into the
hottest possible hollywood version of
yourself it's like glamour on steroids
and unsurprisingly these apps are
exploding in popularity the most popular
one i'm not going to say its name has
1.5 million doctored images downloaded
from it every single day and platforms
like snapchat and instagram now have a
range of different beauty filters built
in for people to choose from oh and not
to mention tick tock who were recently
discovered to have been automatically
applying a very subtle beauty filter to
people's faces without even asking them
yay technology no but seriously this
stuff is dark like believe me when i
tell you that it can very easily train
you to hate your natural face and at
least when i was a teenager the worst i
could do to myself was
compare my face to hot celebrities in
magazines
whereas teenagers today well they are
stuck comparing their faces to the
hottest possible versions of themselves
so god knows what that's doing to them
well i'll give you a clue they ain't
doing great
and so of course to the most important
question who who we blame
well unfortunately the answer isn't as
obvious as it might seem because this is
actually down to something much larger
than any one particular influencer or
app
what's really driving it is a force and
it's a force so ancient and powerful it
can turn anything even something as
lovely as beauty itself down a dark path
if we're not careful
[Music]
now the desire for physical beauty has
long been a core part of nature and the
main reason for this is sexual selection
which is this somewhat controversial
part of evolutionary theory which
suggests that all things being equal
animals would rather mate with the
fittest and healthiest members of their
species over the weaker ones
and it was from this pickiness that the
phenomenon of physical beauty likely
emerged because it kind of acted as a
visual signal of that health and
vitality and if history is anything to
go by us humans aren't much different we
just care about looking hot and we like
looking at hot people and this trend
doesn't seem to be slowing down in 2019
the beauty industry was worth over half
a trillion dollars for the first time
which to put into context is more than
the entire space industry
so yeah despite all our societal
advances and highbrow modern values it's
pretty clear that as a species we still
care about looking hot you know it's
just a core part of our nature
and you know what else is a core part of
human nature
competition
[Music]
competition is
everywhere whether it's over speed
strength intellect even hotness we just
love competing against each other and
even though some of us might be more
naturally competitive than others you
cannot be serious there's definitely
some deep primal force within each of us
making us want to win stuff and this
force can be an incredible motivator
driving us to achieve unbelievable feats
and it can also be a great force for
social good accelerating things like
innovation and progress even something
as collaborative as science has
benefited from it with things like
awards and prizes that act as additional
incentivizers
but that said there comes a point where
too much competition gets unhealthy
where players either through the design
of the game itself or just through their
own short-sightedness end up doing
things that are not only bad for their
opponents but even for themselves and in
some cases for the wider world too
and these things are where my co-star
molok comes in
now i'll go into much more depth on
molok in the next video but for now just
think of it as the god of unhealthy
competition
a god that is so short-sighted and
obsessed with winning it doesn't
appreciate the damage it causes
and this force of monarch can affect
almost any type of competitive system
from something as small as a family game
of monopoly all the way up to religious
or socio-political ideologies competing
for global dominance
but today i just want to focus on how
molok might be infecting the world of
beauty because if all these faith
filters and growing numbers of depressed
teenagers is anything to go by is
getting pretty dark
oh come on you're making me seem like
some kind of monster here i simply enjoy
watching people compete for fun sexy
prizes
and what's a better prize than being
beautiful and having lots of followers
it's not my fault some people get
carried away sometimes and besides dog
eat dog competition is what drives
evolution forward and look at all the
beautiful wonders it's created
yeah but the thing is not all these
physical adornments are necessarily good
for the individual animals like sure
peacock feathers might look beautiful to
us and presumably pretty good to female
peacocks too but in reality they make it
very hard for the male peacock to fly
because they're really heavy and they
make him more conspicuous to predators
so it's an example of where the pursuit
of beauty can get decoupled from what's
actually healthy
and this moment of decoupling can happen
to us humans too you know where we
become so overly obsessed with our
physical appearance in some way that it
ends up taking a toll both on our bodies
and also our minds
well surely the amount of time or money
people spend on their appearance is
their own responsibility
yes well obviously we have some degree
of responsibility over our own
well-being and i'm certainly a big
believer in letting people make their
own choices but that said there are
certain situations where we only really
have the illusion of choice where
bad powerful incentives can get us sort
of trapped in an unhealthy competitive
spiral that's really hard to escape from
like imagine a professional model who's
so fed up with all her clients
photoshopping her photos that she
promises herself and all her friends
that she's going to refuse to do any
jobs that use digital retouching sounds
honorable but can she actually do that
well no not if she wants to keep her job
because it's such a highly competitive
industry that the moment she refuses
they'll just replace her with another
girl who will and while it might seem
obvious that all the girls should just
then band together and sort of create
some anti-photoshop packed in reality
there's tens of thousands of models
worldwide and so it's almost impossible
to coordinate amongst them all to sort
of simultaneously do that but even if
they do manage to get one going it won't
last long because there's always some
girl who needs the money so much she'll
end up breaking it and then another girl
will notice that and break it too
and the next one and the next one until
the whole thing falls apart and they're
back to where they started
well then surely it's the result of all
those evil photographers choosing
prophets over their model's happiness
no it's not even really their fault
because they can't let their photo
shoots get ruined by an uneven skin tone
because then they won't get hired by the
beauty brands and the beauty brands well
they've got their own competitive game
going on if they don't use these
technologies and their competitors will
get ahead of them too and you can keep
just sort of going down and down
throughout the entire sort of social
media beauty industrial complex until
you reach the bottom you know what's
there you molok you and your bad
incentives
you're acting like this is even a bad
thing did you not see what women look
like back in the day all these
technological beauty weapons i've given
you means that even the most average of
you can look hotter than the hottest
women of the middle ages once you're all
dolled up
yeah can't really argue with that
because actually a lot of this stuff
does just make us look better and to be
clear i'm a big fan of most of it in
fact makeup is one of my favorite forms
of art
but kind of like my example of the
unhappy models and the peacock feathers
i suspect that these face filter apps
are the ultimate example of how molecule
forces can twist the pursuit of beauty
to a dark place because social media
influencing is only getting more and
more competitive and these apps are just
so damn insidious like look what this
one does to angelina she's arguably one
of the most beautiful women on earth and
it still finds a way to make her look
hotter only in very subtle and hard to
detect ways
how can this be good for anyone's
self-esteem in the long run
well the short answer is it's not with
maybe the exception of one person
because i tried this app out on a number
of famous faces there was only one
person's whose face curiously didn't
change much that's right the queen of
instagram herself kim kardashian now
maybe that's just because her photos are
already filtered or as i suspect she's
who this particular apps ai is trained
on but either way these apps just make
you feel horrible they're just so cheap
and easy and effective at what they do
it's it's like opening a pandora's box
of self-loathing and in fact there's
even a term for this now snapchat
dysmorphia which was coined by plastic
surgeons after they noticed so many
people coming to them begging to be
changed to look like their filtered
selfies which some experts are referring
to as a full-on mental health crisis
what new technology doesn't have some
downsides here or there it's not my
fault if you dumb girls go too far with
it besides it now means that anyone who
wants to make a living as a beauty
influencer now can uh no because that's
not how the economy works especially not
now that it is literally the number one
most desired job of gen z but look at
all the ones that have made it it means
that anyone could be the next viral
sensation too even you surely that means
it's worth it no i don't think it's
worth anything to raise a generation of
young people who think that being the
next kim kardashian or whoever is some
kind of lofty ambition i mean this
social media game it's a dream come true
isn't it more and more kids abandoning
their previous hopes and dreams in order
to chase after some utterly unattainable
prize and meanwhile ignoring all the
other career paths that are actually
valuable and who are you to judge their
form of career choice talking down from
your high horse when you are literally
an influencer too yeah but that's the
thing i'm not judging them i'm judging
you moloch for making us feel like our
latest social media numbers are all that
matter i'm judging you for turning
beauty and art and creativity from fun
activities into this vapid attention
game of who can score the most followers
and honestly i'm so sick of your
influence creeping into everything i
just want to quit this social media rat
race entirely
well that's quite enough of my acting uh
i guess i've been watching a little bit
too much contra points um for those of
you who don't know she's the queen of
acting out dialogues with different
characters that she's created uh so
hopefully it's given you a little bit of
an overview of what this idea of molok
is um and i'm gonna do a much deeper
dive in the next video in fact i'm gonna
do a whole series on malloc because
as you may have guessed it it applies to
things
much larger than face filters in fact
it's kind of the root cause behind all
sorts of things from
outrageous healthcare prices to nuclear
arms races i mean even climate change in
fact so if any of those things are of
interest to you then do make sure you
catch the next episode also if you'd
like to read a bit more about molok
before because i know not the fastest uh
check out the blog i've linked below
called meditations on malloc by scott
alexander because
honestly that's the inspiration behind
this episode and the entire series it's
one of the most
formative pieces of writing i've ever
read um it's absolutely fascinating so
if you like this then do check it out
anyway uh that's enough for me now here
in my little den of madness that's
disgusting uh and my completely unmade
up face a deliberate choice obviously
for dramatic effect here we are this is
it
this is actually quite intense posting
this um
see you soon and until then just
remember don't hate the players hate the
game